>> Laura: TIME FOR SEEN AND
UNSEEN WHERE WE EXPOSE THE BIG
CULTURAL STORIES OF THE DAY.
WHY ARE RESEARCHERS CALLING A
CHILDHOOD GAME DEHUMANIZING AND
OPPRESSIVE?
WE HAVE A WARNING ABOUT A NEW
SHOW PUSHING DANGEROUS
BOUNDARIES.
RAYMOND ARROYO, FOX NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR AND "NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST-SELLING AUTHOR.
I NEED TO GET THIS WARNING OUT
ABOUT THIS LATEST HBO SHOW.
>> IT'S CALLED "EUPHORIA" AND IT
TARGETS TEENS, IT BILLS ITSELF
AS AN EDGY TRUE OF LIFE
DEPICTION OF GROWING UP TODAY
BUT IT'S GRAPHIC,, VIOLENCE,
CRAZY DRUNK USE AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE.
IT FEATURES FORMER DISNEY STAR
ZENDAYA, I CAN'T DESCRIBE THE
EVENTS BUT ONE CAST MEMBER WAS
SO DISGUSTED BY THE CONTENT AND
THE ADVENTURES THAT WERE
INTRODUCED INTO THE SCRIPT.
HE WALKED OFF THE SET, HBO'S
BOSSES WERE CONCERNED ABOUT THE
MALE IN THE SHOW AND IF THEY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT IT, YOU KNOW
THIS MUST BE BAD.
MY PROBLEM IS AS A PARENT, YOU
ARE PUSHING BOUNDARIES AND
ESTABLISHING AS NORMATIVE THESE
DEVIANT BEHAVIORS,
TRANSGENDERRISM, GENDER
FLUIDITY, RIDICULOUS DRUG USE
AND PASSING IT OFF AS NORMAL.
SAM LEVENSON SPENT TIME IN AND
OUT OF REHAB UP UNTIL HE WAS 16,
OF COURSE THIS WAS NORMAL FOR
HIM LIVING AN ELITE HOLLYWOOD
LIFE, IT WAS NOT NORMAL FOR
AMERICANS.
>> Laura: I THINK I GOT RID OF
HBO -- I WAS LIKE IT'S NOT
SOMETHING I CARE TO PAY FOR, I'M
NOT GOING TO PAY EXTRA FOR IT
AND I'M NOT GOING TO ALLOW IT IN
MY HOME.
WE DON'T WATCH ALMOST ANY TV
ANYMORE.
>> THIS IS BEYOND PUSHING THE
ENVELOPE.
>> Laura: IT'S AN AGENDA AND
THEY ARE PUSHING THIS AGENDA.
SPEAKING OF BAD BEHAVIOR, PEOPLE
ARE CHARGING THE U.S. WOMEN'S
SOCCER TEAM WITH BEING POOR
SPORTS AFTER THE WORLD CUP
VICTORY OVER THAILAND THIS WEEK,
WHAT'S GOING ON?
>> THIS IS THE LARGEST MARGIN OF
WORLD CUP HISTORY, 13-0, BUT
SOME COMMENTATORS AND A FEW
ANCHORS THOUGHT THE U.S. TEAM
WAS GRATUITOUS AND THE WAY THEY
CELEBRATED AFTER EACH POINT WAS
SCORED.
LATE IN THE GAME THEY WERE STILL
HUGGING AND CHEERING AND
ENCOURAGING EACH OTHER.
>> Laura: ON GOALS NINE AND
TEN.
>> THEY THOUGHT IT WENT
OVERBOARD.
MY PROBLEM IS THIS, WHETHER YOU
LOSE OR YOU WIN, RACE MATTERS IN
SPORTS.
LET'S FACE IT, WE HAVEN'T SEEN A
LOT OF EXAMPLES OF THIS, YOU ARE
MEMBER SERENA WILLIAMS LAST YEAR
YELLING AT THAT REF?
SHE WAS FINED HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
YOU HAVE FOOTBALL PLAYERS WHO GO
OVERBOARD WHEN THEY MAKE A
GOAL -- WE NEED TO TEACH GRACE.
I DON'T THINK THIS TEAM CROSSED
THE LINE AT ALL, PUSHED IT TO
THE LIMIT, YOU PLAY TO THE
WHISTLE BLOWS, THAT'S HOW YOU
PLAY THE GAME PARTICULARLY AT
THIS LEVEL.
>> Laura: THE U.S. WOMEN'S
TEAM IS UNREAL.
THAT'S BRUTAL TO LOSE BY THAT
MUCH BUT MAYBE NOT PUT IT IN
THEIR FACE.
>> VANCOUVER RESEARCHERS ARE
DECLARING DODGEBALL
DEHUMANIZING, THEY SAY IT HARMS
THEIR PEERS.
THEY SAY IT CAN BE AN OUTLET FOR
AGGRESSION THAT LEADS TO
EXPLOITATION, POWERLESSNESS AND
VIOLENCE.
THE CRUELTY OF IT.
>> YOU'VE GOT TO LEARN THE FIVE
Cs OF DODGEBALL.
DODGE, DUCK, DIP, DIVE, AND
DODGE.
>> THAT'S WHAT THIS SACK OF
WRENCHES IS FOR.
IF YOU CAN DODGE A WRENCH, YOU
CAN DODGE A BALL.
[GROANING]
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS?
>> Laura: I LOVE "DODGEBALL."
>> WE LEARNED THAT JAMES CORDEN
CORDEN'S LATE SHOW WILL BE
HOSTING A TRANSATLANTIC
DODGEBALL TEAM.
GUESS WHO WILL BE LEADING THE
AMERICAN TEAM?
MICHELLE OBAMA.
BACK AT THE TOP AND UP.
>> Laura: YOU THINK I WASN'T
USUALLY PICKED FIRST?
>> I WOULD GET BEHIND THE BIG
GUYS AND WAITED OUT.
>> IT WAS A SMART IDEA TO INVITE
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS INTO THE
OVAL.
>> Laura: THEY GAVE HIM TWO
DAYS WITH THE PRESIDENT, A BIG
SPECIAL ON ABC.
WE WENT ALL THE WAY ACROSS THE